if you were looking to get your heart
melted today
well we've got you covered
fox news reports a second grade class at
st michael's school in richmond virginia
is learning about persuasive writing and
to practice they're writing adopt me
letters for local dogs at the shelter
each student was assigned a dog and then
briefed on their personality and then
they wrote letters from the dogs asking
to be adopted here's a sample
hello i'm potato chip i make pitbull i
won't hurt you i'll give you lots of
kisses slurp i like the animal shelter
but i want to live with you oh come on
they wrote letters for 24 dogs and one
cat and so far now eight pets have found
their forever home
[Applause]
this one gets me
i know i mean
is this not like a potential new model
too because
you know we're looking you know i'm a
huge advocate for
animal rescue um and this would be such
a game changer it's such a heartbreaking
process then kids get to learn empathy
and writing skills then the you know
customers who are out there searching
get a little sense of the animals it
could really change the whole experience
i mean eight adoptions like you could
double the game here you're so right
this is a model that should be in
schools across the country because it
teaches not only the writing skills but
empathy cause and effect how you can
make a difference these little kids are
doing this it's incredible
i even
and it helps with when you're adopting
to get a little insight into that animal
yeah you know my wellington is um in
charge of curriculum at a school uh a
district in long island i sent this to
him online i'm like now i don't tell you
what to do because you know what you're
doing but you got to do this because
this is so it just moved me so much it
moves me so much well let's see what he
does with this and maybe a suggestion if
anybody wants to take it just keep this
going it's so wonderful please thank you
for doing that you're an example to us
all let's keep this going
[Music]